[MUSIC PLAYING]
RIKU INOUE: Thanks for coming.
So welcome to the
customer successes
with machine learning session.
My name is Riku Inoue.
I'm a project manager of
the cloud machine learning.
So today, I'd like to
share some real stories
from cloud customers,
Google Cloud customers, who
used machine learning to solve
their core business use cases.
So last year at Google
Cloud Next conference,
our chairman, Eric Schmidt,
made a very bold statement
about machine learning.
So he basically said machine
learning is the next paradigm
shift of programming
and it's going
to be one of the strongest
driving force of businesses
worldwide.
So I was at the conference in
2016, and I was very excited.
And still, when you looked
at where the machine learning
applications are coming
from, a lot of concentration
was from tech companies.
However, fast-forward
one year, and we
are seeing an explosion of
machine learning applications
across lots of industries.
It's not just tech.
It's from everywhere,
from manufacturing,
financial services, commerce.
And today, I truly feel that the
transformation Eric mentioned
is actually happening.
So I have been talking
with a lot of companies
from lots of
different industries.
And amazingly, none
of them ever told me
that, oh, our
business does nothing
to do with machine learning.
Everyone in any industry had
some interesting and unique use
cases they want to tackle
with machine learning.
Or some of them are
already building
the actual applications to
solve their business problems.
So this is just a short snippet
of the lots of different needs.
We're going to touch on
some of these use cases,
but it's already too long to go
one by one in this talk, right?
And to unlock these
use cases, people
need great tool sets that
anyone can use and get
the results fast.
And TensorFlow has
been such a tool
to enable people
to actually build
machine learning
solutions without being
a researcher of
machine learning.
So TensorFlow is, as
you know, an open source
library that Google
released in late 2015.
Since then, we have been
seeing a tremendous amount
of support and momentum
from the ML community
as well as people
who just started
to use machine learning.
So in a sense,
TensorFlow is really
democratizing machine
learning for a lot of us.
And machine learning engine
is a fully managed service
where you can run
TensorFlow training
and prediction at scale on
Google's cloud infrastructure.
And today, we just announced
the general availability
of machine learning engine.
And using ML Engine,
what you can do
is write your powerful
machine learning algorithm
using TensorFlow,
run the training
with terabytes of data--
it's not just gigabytes,
terabytes of real big data--
and deploy the model
with just one command,
and serve the prediction
for millions of users,
and do that without worrying
about building your machine
learning infrastructure
or maintaining that,
which takes away the time.
So we'd like you
to basically focus
on building great machine
learning applications
instead of managing
your infrastructure.
So using these tools,
using machine learning
to transform your business
is not a topic of future,
but it's the topic of today.
And in this session, I'd like to
share seven stories from Google
Cloud customers who
have taken advantage
of machine learning to apply
that to their core business
problems.
And some of them had this
problem for a very, very long
time, like decades.
So hopefully, you can get
some ideas and inspirations
about how you can use machine
learning to solve your business
problems or improve your
apps, improve your customer
experience.
So our first story is from AXA.
They are one of the largest
global insurance firms.
And they used machine
learning to solve
a problem for one of
their core business, which
is car insurance.
So here's a little bit
of an interesting number
for car insurance.
So out of all insured drivers,
about 7% to 10% of drivers
get into an accident.
And most of these
accidents are minor.
It requires just a small fix-up.
But 1% of all these
accidents is large.
And that requires over
$10,000 of insurance payment.
And they call it large-loss
car accident cases.
And it is very important
for an insurance company
to understand the risk
of somebody getting
into such large car accidents.
So what they did was to
take the information that
typically they use to
evaluate these risks--
there are 70 features they used.
There are things like age range
of the driver, the region,
the information about
their insurance policy--
and feed them into
a neural network
that has three hidden
layers and ReLU activation.
And they got the amazing
result of 78% accuracy, which
was a huge jump from
their previous method
that was using
random forest, which
is another machine
learning algorithm.
And with this kind of
accuracy, this basically
enables better
pricing for customers.
Also, it opens up the
possibility of better services,
like real-time insurance
pricing, which also benefits
the customer experience.
So let's take a look
at the data in action
in the neural network.
So they created this
very cool visualization
to actually showcase the neural
network training in action.
So on the right-hand
side, there are
lots of features fed
into the neural network.
And the lines are the connection
inside the neural network.
The boxes are the neurons.
And the training started.
And the color orange and blue
means positive and negative
values.
And you can see the
thickness representing
the weight of the connection.
And training goes on.
And on the right-hand
side, you can
see the graph of test accuracy.
So that is the accuracy
score for the test data set
that is held out from
the training data set.
It is very important in machine
learning to segregate these two
data sets.
And you can see the
training is converging.
And after some
amount of time, it
gets to quite high number of 78.
So that was a very
cool visualization.
So that was an example
from insurance industry.
Our next story is from
Airbus Defence and Space.
So many of you might
know the name Airbus.
And Airbus Defense and Space
is a world-leading company
in the space industry.
So they had this
problem to detect clouds
in satellite imagery
for 20 years.
So they are the experts
in this problem,
and they have been
devising the solution
to solve this
problem for 20 years.
And here's one example image--
so snow-capped mountains,
and there are clouds.
And it's really hard to
see, but here is the answer.
So if you were able to tell
all the pieces of clouds,
then congratulations.
You have very,
very good eyesight.
So it's very, hard
even for humans.
And the process naturally
involves a lot of manual work
to accurately tag these clouds.
And as the amount of data that
come through their pipeline
increases day by day and at the
level of 10,000 images per day,
their manual process
no longer can
scale to sustain that workload.
So what they did was to
create machine learning-based,
automated approach to
tackle this problem.
And they got an amazing result
of reducing the error rate
from 11% with their
production system
to 3% with the new approach.
And what's even more amazing is
the speed of their development.
So they got the first
promising result
with their proof of concept
within the first month
of their trial.
So when you think
about the time frame,
they had this
problem for 20 years.
And one month of intense
project, and they
got a 70% reduction of errors.
So you can imagine how joyful
they were to find this result.
And with this new
approach, basically, they
can use order of
hundreds of hours
per week of human time,
the precious human time,
to even more challenging task
that require human processing.
And here is a very brief
summary of their approach.
So they combined multiple
convolutional neural networks
that goes through different--
the images go through different
kind of image processing
to capture different
aspects of the image.
And they connect these
networks with fully connected
neural network.
So this is quite a
huge network to train.
So it's very computationally
intensive to train.
So they used ML Engine's
GPU training capability
to accelerate the training.
And they got the amazing
acceleration of 40 times speed.
So that is pretty good.
And also, they used the
distributed training.
So in total, they used to
have 50 hours of training time
on their desktop machine.
So that's quite a long time.
You need to wait for a few days.
And they reduced the time to
30 minutes on cloud ML Engine.
And with that kind of time,
basically you can start the job
and go grab some coffee and
do a small chat, come back,
and then the result
is already there.
And you can iterate on that.
So it enables a
very fast iteration
to improve the model quality
in a very short amount of time.
Also, they used the feature
called HyperTune on ML engine
that basically automates
the hyperparameter tuning.
And hyperparameter
tuning, some of you
may know that it is a
very manual process that
takes quite a lot of time.
And HyperTune basically
do that on behalf of you
so that you can be more
productive on improving
your model.
And the third story we have
is from Global Fishing Watch.
They have a very ambitious
goal of preventing
overfishing across the globe.
And they do that by
providing transparency
over the fishing activities
happening across the ocean.
And that's a very
big-scale problem.
And overfishing is actually
a very severe problem that
is relevant to a lot of us.
Fish is a very
important food source.
And also, the resource
is under stress.
The fishing stock across the
ocean is decreasing rapidly.
And part of the reason why this
problem is so hard to catch
is understanding the
activities on the ocean
takes a lot of
manual monitoring,
and the existing
approach doesn't scale.
So they created machine
learning-based approach
and enabled watching the
entire surface of the ocean.
That is more than
140 square miles.
Now, that is a
really big number.
It's really hard to grasp.
So to put that into the
context, it's 37 times
the entire United States,
which is quite a large area
to monitor.
And they created the model to
analyze the movement patterns
of vessels to classify different
kinds of boats and ships,
and then also understand exactly
when and where the fishing
activities are happening.
And here's a little
illustration of different kinds
of movement patterns.
And as you can see, there's
very distinct movement patterns.
And also, there are non-fishing
vessels, like cargo ships.
So it's important to
distinguish these as well.
And their approach was
convolutional neural network,
and they had quite
a lot of features.
So 100,000 features
coming into the network,
because there are a
lot of time points.
And each time point
has 11 features.
And again, this takes
quite a lot of computation.
And again, they used the cloud
ML Engine GPU to accelerate.
And they got 10x speed
up and cost performance.
And the important piece here
is the cost performance,
which means basically for
the same amount of dollar,
they got 10x results.
So when GPUs work
for your model,
it is not only very fast.
Also, it's a very much
cheaper solution to use.
And as a result, they
created this visualization
of whole fishing activities.
Each dot represents fishing
happening across the ocean.
And as you can see, the
activity is happening
across a very large area.
And also, there's very
interesting patterns happening
in different time windows.
So that is a very cool use case
of getting insights at scale.
So now we're going to
talk about SparkCognition,
who created a ML-based malware
detection service for Android.
So I'd like to invite Bryan
Lares from SparkCognition
to share that story with us.
BRYAN LARES: Hey.
First of all, so my
name is Bryan Lares.
I'm the director of
product management
for cybersecurity solutions
at SparkCognition.
First, I want to start out
with how much of an honor
it is to be invited on stage
with all these great use cases.
I mean, tremendous
innovation going on
on the ML Engine platform.
And we're just excited to be a
part of it at SparkCognition.
I want to make this interactive.
So let me see a raise of hands.
I'm going to look
around and try to count.
So there was a big story in
the news in the last 24 hours
where Wikileaks announced that
they dropped or identified
about 5,000 different hacking
tools apparently created
by the CIA to hack all
kinds of different devices
from PCs to mobile
devices to even TVs.
Who read the "New York Times?
or "Wall Street Journal" or--
yeah, that's big, big news.
The one that really struck
me the most is there
was a report that Samsung
TVs had been hacked and used
as listening devices as part
of one of these hacking tools.
So just mind-blowing.
Let me ask a follow-up question.
Who here thinks that
we, as a society,
need to use the power
of machine learning
to try to protect our devices
from these kind of hacking
techniques?
Yeah, me too.
So at SparkCognition,
we've created a machine
learning malware
detection engine.
And we've developed
one for Android,
or we're in the process of
developing one for Android
based on the Google ML platform.
I believe we're the first
vendor to actually use
the ML Engine to create
a malware detection
engine for Android.
Perfect.
OK, so the first question
you'd probably ask yourself
is, why apply machine learning
and artificial intelligence
to cybersecurity?
What's changed?
Well, there's really
two megatrends
that are impacting
cybersecurity right
now that just scream for the
need for machine learning.
First of all, the
growth of malware.
So there's a massive amount
of malware created every day
by hackers around
the world, and it's
reached a scale
that's overwhelming
the ability of the
analyst community
to identify and write
signatures for those threats.
Second of all, the growth
of overall devices.
There will be 50 billion
connected devices
on public and private
networks by the year 2020,
exponentially
increasing the attack
surface that needs to be
defended by infosec teams.
So you put those
two trends together,
and it just screams
for the need for what
we call at SparkCognition
"machine scale."
Our amazing marketing team
has put together a short video
talking about how we partnered
with Riku and his team
to develop DeepArmor on
the Google ML platform.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- My name's Bryan Lares.
I'm the director of
product management
for cybersecurity solutions
here at SparkCognition.
DeepArmor is a
machine learning-based
malware detection
engine that we've
developed for both the Windows
and the Android platform.
- DeepArmor solves the problem
of detecting malware using
machine learning techniques
by effectively building
a set of machine
learning classifiers
and then ensembling them
in our own unique way.
- It's like having
a human researcher
go through every
single file and be
able to make a determination
on whether that file's
malicious or benign based on
the inner workings of the code.
- Simply put, we're
building a pipeline that
starts with the
labeled data, the clean
and the malicious applications,
and we're driving that through
from future extraction all the
way into building a classifier,
and then also testing and
then looking at efficacy.
- We found three
primary benefits
to using the Google
machine learning platform.
The first is subsecond
response time.
We're able to analyze new
threats with subsecond response
time from anywhere
around the world.
Number two, it's allowed
us to actually reduce
our overall training time,
which allows us to adapt
to new threats more quickly.
And finally, scalability.
The Google machine
learning platform
has allowed us to quickly
scale to millions of users
without having to
make a large upfront
investment in our [INAUDIBLE].
- The Google machine
learning platform
helps to solve this
problem by simply giving us
a distributed environment
by which to train and build
new models.
So specifically
for DeepArmor, it
allows us to rely on
Google's infrastructure
to perform predictions that
scale with minimal latency.
I joined this company primarily
because of the problems
that we're solving and
the technology that we're
using to solve these problems.
- SparkCognition overall is an
artificial intelligence company
at its heart.
I was attracted
to SparkCognition
for solving I think the
most important problem
of our generation, which is
augmenting human intelligence.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
BRYAN LARES: OK.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] very, very much.
So that's the story
of SparkCognition
or a little bit
about SparkCognition
and how we developed our machine
learning malware detection
engine.
We've actually brought
a prototype with us
that I can kind of walk
you through a user story.
And then I'll tell you
about some of the benefits.
All right.
So here's the simple
use case, right?
And this is-- your
infosec teams are
going to walk you
through similar scenarios
every single time.
So by the way, the gentleman you
saw in the video, Matt Brock,
is here.
He's our lead engineer for
the for our machine learning
malware detection
engine for Android.
So he'll be available
after the discussion.
So imagine that you get an
email from a Matt Brock that
says that he's from
TurboTax, and he's
noticed that there's been
an error in submitting
your return to the IRS.
And if you just click
this one download link,
you'll be able to upgrade
your version of TurboTax
and be able to
resubmit your IRS form.
So me being a good citizen and
really excited about my return,
I will of course be
one to hit that link
and download the file.
So lucky for me,
I've actually started
using the power of
machine learning
to protect my mobile device.
So again, this is the prototype
of our Android solution.
We'll probably be doing market
launch at the end of Q2.
But the goal is
eventually, all we
monitor all the files
and all the file
activity on that device.
And any unknown files,
we're able to analyze
the characteristics
of those files
and make a prediction on whether
it's malicious or benign.
So lo and behold, DeepArmor
identified this file
as malicious with a
98% confidence rating.
So our prediction algorithm
returns a threat confidence
score on how confident
it is that file's
malicious or benign.
And obviously, we can go through
threat remediation activities.
So this is an accurate case.
That file was malicious.
In fact, it's the
Rootnik piece of malware,
which steals information
from the device
and downloads additional
applications to that device.
It also uses very advanced
debugging and antihook
techniques to prevent it from
being reverse-engineered.
So this was actually
live-hitting the Google ML
platform from the room here.
Can we switch back
to the presentation?
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
So here's the architecture.
Here's how we've leveraged
the Google ML platform.
First, obviously, on the
Google ML platform side,
for model training,
we've collected--
the key for malware detection is
collecting a huge, broad sample
set of malicious
or benign files.
In the case of
our Android model,
we've collected over 100,000
malicious and benign files
of a very broad sample set.
Then we actually have--
we've created three
different feature extractors
to be able to
analyze [INAUDIBLE]
three different feature
vectors to analyze
different characteristics
within the files.
Each file can literally
have over 1,000 or thousands
of different
characteristics that we've
put through the
machine learning model.
We then leveraged the
power of TensorFlow
to develop our deep
neural network classifier.
And finally, we deploy that
on the Google ML engine
to do online prediction.
So then I think the second
stage of that is actually
what happens from your device
to actually detect the malware.
So it obviously all starts
with a very small endpoint
agent on your mobile device.
The DeepArmor agent does
file monitoring and feature
extraction.
It then interacts with
our cloud orchestration
layer within our
management console
and to actually do
threat submission.
We then do ingestion
through data proc and data
vectorization.
And then it goes through
the Google ML platform
with the ML Prediction
API for classification,
finally going back to our
DeepArmor cloud orchestration
layer and to our
management console,
and then finally to the
DeepArmor agent for execution,
blocking and alerting.
This whole process can
take less than a second
to actually go from
identifying a new file
on a system to sending it out to
our cloud layer and the Google
ML platform and coming back
with a prediction in less
than a second, which is
obviously critical for the user
experience.
So finally, there's
three major benefits
to applying machine learning
to malware detection.
First of all-- and this is
by far the most important--
we're seeing detection rates
four times more effective
versus zero-day threats
and polymorphic threats
compared to traditional
cybersecurity solutions.
So traditional
solutions sometimes
that are based on
signatures see less than 20%
efficacy for new zero-day
threats and new hacking
techniques.
So machine learning's making a
significant difference in that.
Second is speed.
As I mentioned,
our model combined
with the cloud ML Engine
is optimized to provide
subsecond threat analysis.
And finally, scalability.
Our load profile device agent
combined with the scalability
of the Google ML Engine makes it
possible to apply this approach
to millions of mobile
and IOT devices.
As an example from the
efficacy standpoint,
as we were developing this
model, with our first feature
set, which was strings,
we were able to reach
efficacy rates of greater than
90% on malware and clean files.
When we added in
our API feature sets
and our permissions
feature sets,
we're starting to see
results of over 99%
efficacy for both
malicious and benign files.
So a significant step forward
versus the traditional
cybersecurity solutions.
So our goal at
SparkCognition is to use
the power of
artificial intelligence
to provide more effective
and more cost-efficient
security to all
types of devices.
And we think that this
cloud-based model, partnering
with Google, can be
scaled to all kinds
of different
solutions from mobile
to IoT to servers to clients.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RIKU INOUE: Thanks, Bryan.
It was an amazing demo.
So going back to the
slides, the next story
is from financial services.
So SMFG is one of the largest
financial service companies
in Japan--
Sumitomo Mitsui Financial Group.
And they partnered
with JSOL, which
is a GCP partner
in Japan who has
a lot of experience in
data analytics and also
financial industry.
And they created ML-based credit
card fraud detection system.
So credit card fraud is
probably something familiar.
Since like last few
years, I got already
like two credit card
fraud issues happening
with my personal card.
I don't know how people
get that information,
but this is a big problem
that's relevant to many of us.
And it's a huge amount of impact
of $5.5 billion every year
in the financial industry.
And some types of frauds
are very hard to detect,
and they have a rule-based
system in production.
They have been maintaining this
system for quite a long time.
When a threat or
a fraud requires
lots of complex rules
and combinations of them,
typically, it's very hard to
detect and as low as 5% to 10%
of the detection rate.
And with that kind
of rate, pretty much
you need humans to intervene and
have the check after the system
returns the results.
And they created an
automated approach
to basically monitor
that approval results
so that instead of doing
the manual intervention,
basically you can automatically
capture these frauds.
And they got amazing
80% to 90% accuracy,
even for the most difficult
ones that had like 5% to 10%
of the accuracy.
And they used deep neural
network for doing this.
And they estimate that it
has millions of dollars
of impact for their business.
And the story doesn't stop here.
And they are
working on basically
making the system adaptive
by using machine learning
and basically analyze
the trends of the frauds
and new fraud patterns
happening and adapt the system.
Also, SMFG has quite
a lot of ambition
in terms of integrating machine
learning into their core
business.
And one of the future
efforts they are doing
is to basically predict the
future financial changes
of companies.
So understanding
company financials
is a very manual process, again.
And it has a very long
lead time as well.
So every quarter, companies
publicize the financial results
a statement.
And analysts analyze that.
And then after that, the
banks know, oh, some change
is happening.
So what they are trying
to do is to basically make
the process more real-time by
analyzing real-time deposit
and withdrawal data and
monitor that with the AI
they are building to basically
predict the performance
change in the future at
much earlier frame rather
than catching that
after something happened
and they see the
financial statements.
So they have quite a lot of
very interesting use cases.
And the machine
learning solutions
are very promising business
activities for them.
So the next story
is quite different.
It's from food industry.
Kewpie is the number one brand
for food quality and safety
in Japan.
And as you may know, Japan
has incredibly high standard
for products.
And it's quite a big deal to
have consumers selecting them
as the number one brand.
And they make really
good mayonnaise.
And if you love mayonnaise,
I recommend to try it.
So they partnered with
BrainPad, which is
another GCP partner in Japan.
They have a lot of experience
in integrating machine learning
solutions into customers'
business processes.
And their problem was to
detect defective potato cubes
in the production line.
Ultimately, this
becomes tasty stew.
And in order to make
very high-quality food,
catching defective raw
materials is very important.
And they have the highest
standard in food quality.
And in many cases, the
raw materials they reject
are actually just fine
industry standards.
So you can see the
kind of obsession
to the quality they have.
And this is an example
picture of these potato cubes.
And I invite you to actually
detect two defects in here.
It's pretty hard, right?
And here's the answer.
So as you can see, it's very
hard and it's very subtle.
And also, there are
so many different ways
that defects can happen that
it's really hard to automate.
And they tried
using machines that
cost like more than $100,000,
and they couldn't do the task.
So they're relying on
good inspection workers,
and it is a very, very
tiring task for them.
You need to keep very keen
focus on the production
line for hours to do this task.
So they created
something they call
a worker-friendly
inspection AI that
achieved a similar level of
accuracy as human inspectors.
And what it does
is basically, it
monitors the video feed
from the production line
and makes a sound when
it detects the defects.
And the worker knows,
oh, there is a defect,
and they can pick
up the material.
And this makes the work
much easier for the worker.
And so here is the friendliness
of this AI to workers.
And we have a very
cool video that they
sent us to show you
the system in action.
So this is the
prototype machine.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RIKU INOUE: And you can see
potato cubes flowing down.
And you will hear the sound.
[TONES PLAYING]
And the different tone
means different locations
on the belt-- center
or left or right.
And probably, you couldn't
really detect the defects here,
so I'm going to play this again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
RIKU INOUE: I tried again and
again, and I still can't do it.
So you can see how hard the task
is and how good the system is.
And another note is that
this batch is the test set,
so it has a lot more defects
artificially included
in the batch.
So with this success,
they practically
saved more than
$100,000 per line.
And also, they got these
results in only six months.
And they are quite amazed
at this very fast turnaround
because typically, this kind
of project in their industry
takes really long time--
much more than six months.
And their approach is basically
to combine traditional image
processing technique and
deep neural network approach
to detect anomaly
in size and color.
So they did a creative
approach to combine the kind
of conventional and new.
And I invite you to come
to see the [INAUDIBLE] demo
on the third floor at the
Big Data and Machine Learning
sandbox.
It's a similar concept
of basically using robots
to do the task you want.
And you can voice
control the robot.
It's very fun.
So please drop by.
And our last example
is from commerce.
So Aucnet IBS, they are the
largest, real-time car auction
service in Japan.
And they list 5 million
cars every year.
And 30,000 car dealers
depend on their system
to run their business.
So it's quite a large
scale operation.
And each listed car
requires 30 photos
for interiors and exteriors.
And what they have been doing is
basically sorting these images
manually, because
the images are very
important for these
listings, and they
need to make this right.
And this takes like
five minutes per car.
And add that up for 5 million
cars, you do the math.
It's a lot of time consuming.
And you need to know
what model, what make,
what year, and which parts,
and what angles are missing.
And doing that sounds
like a perfect thing
to do with machine learning.
So they created an
image classifier
that does the classification
of model, make and year
as well as which parts they are.
And they got to
95% accuracy, which
is quite high and completely
enough for production use.
So I'm going to show a
little demo of their system.
Let me log to my computer.
So please switch to
the demo machine.
So here is their demo system.
And I have a bunch
of photos of a car.
So unless you're very
familiar with lots of cars,
you wouldn't know exactly
what year, what make.
So I'll drop this here.
So it's uploading.
And in real-time, they
are doing the recognition.
You can see the
confidence score coming in
for each different image.
And it's now 55%.
Lots of time is spent actually
on uploading the photo itself.
So it's getting there.
So we got the
result. So it looks
like this is 2012 Toyota
Land Cruiser Prado.
And they have the price range.
And also, they have
different angles got right.
And you can see the
confidence score here as well.
It's very confident about the
angles and the parts, tires,
and under the car, even engine.
So they can effectively
sort the images
and detect what's missing.
And it saves a lot of time when
they go through 5 million car
listings every year.
So please go back
to the presentation.
On the approach they took
to build this classifier is
something very, very useful.
It's called transfer learning.
And the concept of transfer
learning is quite simple.
So you take pre-trained model.
Let's say, in this
case, Inception v3.
And it's already trained
on millions of images,
and it's open sourced.
So you can get your
hands on these models
and then chop off
last few layers that
does the classification
and add new layers
and retrain using
your own image.
And the benefit of this
is the base model already
have learned how to extract
features and understand
the basic components of images.
And you save a lot of
time doing these training
for millions of images.
And with the new image
set, basically you
need a lot smaller number
of training data set.
In their case, they used 200
training images per class.
So for one car, you
only need 200 images,
which is a lot less when you
compare from scratch training.
So it saves your time.
It saves your amount of data.
So it's a very
versatile method to use.
And they used ML Engine's
distributed training
to do the speedup.
And they got 84
times faster speed
using 100 workers, 100
nodes, for training.
So they got from 28 hours on a
single machine to 20 minutes.
Again, this enables a lot
faster iteration on your model.
And since transfer learning
is quite a useful method,
if you're interested in building
your own image classifier,
we have a blog post that
basically step-by-step explains
how to do transfer
learning on ML engine.
So please go to this
link or simply Google
"Cloud ML transfer learning."
So we have been seeing
a lot of examples.
And at this point,
I hope that you're
convinced that
machine learning is
valuable to a lot of industries.
And I invite you
to really consider
today starting to look into how
you can use machine learning.
And GCP can help
your [INAUDIBLE].
We provide two broad
categories of products.
One is pre-trained models--
so visual API, speech API,
translate, natural language.
And we announced the video
intelligence API today.
Using these without any
knowledge about machine
learning, you can take
advantage of the power
of machine learning.
And when you want to
build your own custom
solution using your own
data, you can use ML Engine.
And ML Engine supports
your whole life cycle
of machine learning, from
data to understanding
the data, pre-processing the
data, training, and prediction.
And as the next
step, I recommend
you to join some
of our ML sessions.
There is a lot.
This is a subset of these.
These are especially
relevant when
you are trying to
build your own models
and learn how to do this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]